how's it going guys how you doing it's
wonderful good i'm a bit of a fanboy i
gotta say like i saw the hamilton show
when it came to toronto in february but
i've been listening to the soundtrack
for
i don't know how many years so i'm very
excited to finally see with my eyes so
you guys do the show as opposed to
sharing with my ears so yeah i'm very
excited
have you guys seen this yet i have yes i
have not yeah
yeah yeah so like chris what talking
about the concept
of seeing yourself in a broadway show
because normally you don't get that
opportunity right so it was like
watching you do this
i'd be lying if if i wasn't sort of
micromanaging every movement and
and and correcting a little bit but i
have to tell you
the truly enjoyable part for me was
watching uh like
my co-stars and and and and i by co-star
i mean
every single person on that stage there
is a
there's just there's a strength and a
power and a joy
and just a a level of excellence that
i haven't witnessed ever and just
just in watching that that film uh
reminded me of just how
uh specific the casting was uh and and
watching everyone sort of execute
through their own specific skill set was
was pretty remarkable yeah david what
are you most excited to see
when you see it same i'm i'm very
excited to just watch
get to get to relive some of those
moments and and
uh see everybody be brilliant i you know
and and
in ways that i've never gotten to see
them before you always watch the show
from your particular vantage point as
you're moving through it so i'm excited
to get to
sit in in this these specific audience
seats and
and watch them where do you keep your
tony that you got
david yeah where do you keep your tony
levy
i don't i don't know it's i mean i it's
wherever the shot glasses are
do you guys have a favorite number from
the show
all of them and none of them for me like
i
i mean wait for it's probably my
favorite you know
um because i kind of was a spectator in
that
just given where i was in the show um
but
i just love that song so much um
yeah yeah wait for it and and
one last time were moments i got to
watch really so
those are my favorite because i i got to
i got to actually see them be performed
every night right
and uh i know like everyone's going to
be able to watch this at home but david
you get to
got to go to the first like red carpet
on wednesday
this overnight team times what was that
like uh for me
anxiety-inducing i probably would do it
again for quite some time
you know it was socially distant it was
very safe it was all the photographers
were masks it was it was a good
exercise and maybe ways to do this but
like i'm not actually ready for that
i don't think i was happy to support
those artists and
um and the film was great but i just i'm
i'm
i'm not there yet and i'll be getting
tested again in a week and again a week
after that and i'm like
totally my anxiety's through the roof
because of it so
yeah no in terms of releasing this in
this
uh movement of black lives matter what
do you think the significance is of
releasing this now chris you're going to
start
um you know hamilton has has done
the work that the show itself has done
as as its own entity
uh in terms of garnering attention and
and support
and enthusiasm my hope is is that
because you know
a great piece of art will change in its
complexion
as the the context around it changes
um and so my hope is is that people
will see a better representation of the
and and the reflection of themselves
that young people would be motivated
to to further participate in this moment
that we're in
um and if this is an expression of a
former age of enlightenment i hope that
is a harbinger of a
of a new age of enlightenment in which
we all can
can put aside our old norms and get to
the real work of of
of creating this this equitable you know
society for every for the least of these
for the for the for those of us
who are are are keenly aware of what has
been accepted for so long
um i hope that hamilton is a reflection
of of of the true ideals of
of what we aspire to
very well said you want anything to read
oh no i i
never have to add on to it well
congratulations guys i can't wait to
watch this i'm so excited